Beschleunigt fliegen, beim beschleunigten Flug ist es wichtig, dass er probiert, die Hände
ganz oben steckt zu halten. Ihr dürft auch, wenn ihr wollt, euch so ein bisschen an den
Liter von Trage wurden halten, weil wir können im beschleunigten Flug nur noch mit Gewichtsverlagerung
steuern. Und wenn das eben nicht ausfeicht, dann nehmen wir noch einen ganzen leichten Zug
an die unterste Trage gut mit. Also das heißt, beschleunigen Gerichten oder wie
beschleunigt man. Wenn er da so wie ich gut in die erste Schlauerei kommt, geht
damit der Fährse in diese erste Schlaufe, drehtet ihr ein bisschen soweit, dass er mit den
zweiten Fuß auf die nächste Stufe zurücksteigen könnt und dann den zweiten Fuß
ebenfalls auf diese Stufe zurückkommt. Ihr seht, ich habe das in den Flexiblen, das haben die meisten
von euch, wenn der Stange hat, geht das ein bisschen einfacher. Ja, dann suchen wir so ein
bisschen diese Metrie mit den Füßen und dann drücken wir den Beschleuniger ganz langsam
folgen. Und im Idealfall ist dann der Beschleuniger, so wie hier rechts, rolle, über
rolle drüber oder zumindest rolle auf, rolle drauf. Hier links
da haben ein bisschen Distanz zwischen den einzelnen Rollen.
Jetzt sind viel das Gründigkeit dadurch, dass wir dann der Geräse Asimmetrie drinnen haben,
wenn ich die Beine weiter rausnehme, dann seht ihr, da haben wir da Symmetrie und die Rollen
bequeren. Das wäre voll beschleunigt und jetzt ist wichtig, steuern nur noch mit
Gewichtsverlagerung, wenn das nicht ausreift, dann dürfen wir ganz leicht am
hindern Trage so ziehen. Also ein Zentimeter, rückstens zwei, also da mal wenig Arbeitsverleicht.
Gut, Beschleuniger ausleiten, einfach neutral hinsetzen oder wenn wir eine Kurve machen
auf die anderen Seite, machen wir die zuerst fertig und dann neutral hinsetzen. Und langsam
zurück aus dem Beschleuniger. Die letzten Trage, Zentimeter, Gründerinnen, von
wir so ausspicken was. Wichtig ist, während dem Beschleunigen Flug ist die nicht mit der
Grenze steuern. Die Erklärung kommt nachher bei der Grenzstelle.